ام
اهلا بكم اصبحت فلسطين دوله متعاقده ساميه
في مواثيق جناب الاربعه كما ان طلبها
بالانضمام بخمس عشره معاهده امميه سيصبح
نافذا ابتداءا من الثاني من ايار مايو
المقبل وفق ما اعلنت الامم المتحده نتوقف
لكي نناقشه في محورين اي ادوات قانونيه
تتيح هذه الخطوه للفلسطينيين في مواجهه
اسرائيل دوليا
وهل هي مناوره للحل عبر المفاوضات ام
جبهات جديده مع اسرائيل
من مناطق محتله او متنازع عليها الى دوله
تحت الاحتلال هكذا سيصبح الوصف القانونى ل
فلسطين في المحافل الدوليه بعدما اقر
انضمامها اليوم الى معاهدات جنيف اهميه
الخطوه الفلسطينيه تكمن في ان اي شخص او
جهه او دوله تستفيد من الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في الضفه الغربيه او في قطاع
غزه ستصبح تحت طائله المساءله القانونيه
على الصعيد الدولي لكن السلطه الفلسطينيه
لن تتقدم بطلب انضمام الى اتفاقيه روما
التي انشات بموجبها محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه وهي خطوه لو تمت ستتيح ملاحقه
كثير من المسؤولين الاسرائيليين
خطوه محسوبه اكد بذلك من امريكي تقدم
الفلسطينيين بطلبات انضمام الى منظمات و
معاهده دوليه ويبدو ان ذلك التحرك بدا
يثمر فقد قبلت فلسطين عضوا متعاقد اساميا
في اتفاقيات جنيف الاربع والبروتوكول
الاضافي الاول يحق لرئيس السلطه
الفلسطينيه محمود عباس ان يصف ما حدث بانه
تاريخ جديد
لجا الرجل الى توقيع طلبات الانضمام لتلك
المواثيق والمعاهدات عقب تعثر المفاوضات
مع الجانب الاسرائيلي
استشاطت حكومه نتنياهو غضبا من خطوه
السلطه الفلسطينيه وفرضت عليها عقوبات
اقتصاديه
منها اقتطاع الديون الماليه عليها من
الضرائب التي تجمعها اسرائيل باسمها كما
قررت وضع حدود على الودائع الخاصه بالسلطه
في بنوك اسرائيل فماذا يمكن ان يتحقق
للفلسطينيين الان الكثير يقول محللون ليس
اقله ان فلسطينيين غدت في منظور القانون
الدولي دوله تحت الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
اصبحتم كانت دوله فلسطين هي على حدود سبعه
وستين وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه هي دوله تحت
الاحتلال تماما كما كانت عليه النرويج
مثلا اه بلجيكيا هولندا فرنسا الفلبين اه
كوريا اثناء الحرب العالميه الثانيه تحتل
الجلالين الالماني والياباني لم يعد اي
اسرائيل يستطيع من الان القول ان هذه
ارضيه عليها ينبه البعض الى ان الانضمام
لاتفاقيه جنيف الرابعه مثلا يعتبر خطوه
تاريخيه تمثل اهميه خاصه للفلسطينيين وهي
تختص بحمايه المدنيين في زمن الحرب اضافه
الى كونها تحدد واجبات سلطات الاحتلال
ويرى الفلسطينيون على الاتفاقيات الدوليه
اذا ما تساهم في ترسيخ الشخصيه القانونيه
لدوله فلسطين كدوله بين الامم كما تساهم
في التصدي لانتهاكات حقوق الشعب الفلسطيني
من قبل السلطه القائمه بالاحتلال
لعل الفلسطينيين احسن اخيرا الاستفاده من
وضع الدوله المراقب غير العضو الذي حاز اه
في الامم المتحده عام الفين واثني عشر فهو
يتيح لهم الانضمام الى مختلف الاتفاقيات
والمعاهدات الدوليه بما في ذلك نظام روما
الاساسي المنشا لمحكمه الجنايات الدوليه
وتلك ورقه ليس خافيا انها تصيب
الاسرائيليين بالظاهر لكن الفلسطينيين قد
يدخرونها في اللحظه المناسبه
لمناقشه هذه القضيه ينضم الينا من القدس
الصحفي الاسرائيلي مايير كوهين من الخليل
الدكتور معتز شو استاذ القانون الدوله في
جامعه الخليل وسوف ينضم الينا ايضا من رام
الله عبد الله عبد الله رئيس اللجنه
السياسيه في المجلس التشريعي الفلسطيني
ولكن انا سابدا مع الدكتور خليل الدكتور
معتز فيتامين الخليل اه دكتور كيف يمكن
اعطاء اثنان
لقبول فلسطين كعضو متعاقد سامي في
اتفاقيات جنيف الاربعه اي كيف موضع موضع
التنفيذ لهذه الاتفاقيات
يعني انا اقول انه عضويه فلسطين في
اتفاقيه جنيف الاربعه سيكون نقطه تحول
تاريخيه
في في تاريخ الصراع الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي
يمكن من خلالها اعتبار مثلا المستوطنات اه
جريمه حرب وايضا اعتبار الاسرى
الفلسطينيين وفقا لاتفاقيه جنيف الثالثه
اسرى حرب وبالتالي اه اه البقاء الابقاء
عليها في السجون الاسرائيليه سيشكل جريمه
حرب وبالتالي هو كل ملاحقه المجرمين
الاسرائيليين بموجب هذه الاتفاقيات اه
سواء في المحاكم المحليه في كل دول العالم
التي هي اطراف في اتفاقيات جنيف الاربع
ويمكن ايضا لفلسطين من الان ان تنضم الى
ميثاق روما الخاص بالمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه وبالتالي ملاحقه المجرمين
الاسرائيليين في مائه واثنين وعشرين دوله
في العالم وهذا يعني ان المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين سيكون مقبلين ولم يستطيعوا
السفر مثلا الى كندا او الى فرنسا
والالبان الى المانيا اولا البرازيل اولى
اليابان او الى غيرها طبعا من دول العالم
الاطراف في ميثاق الامم الخاص بالمحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه وبتقديري ان هذا سيعطي
المفاوض الفلسطيني اه قوه اه كبيره جدا
وسيتيح الفرصه للفلسطينيين للدخول في
مقاومه جديده انا اسميها المقاومه
القانونيه احنا عرفناه خلال الستين سنه
الماضيه المقاومه العسكريه نحنا بالمقاومه
الشعبيه ولكني اقول اننا نحتاج الى
المقاومه القانونيه والتي بتقديري انها
ستكون اقوى من الصواريخ واضعوا اقوى من
الرصاص واقوى من ال من ال من الحجاره لان
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين سياتوا للتفاوض
حول اه اه امكانيه الفلسطينيه
ما جرى الانضمام اليه حتى اللحظه بالنسبه
للمحكمه الجنائيه تحتاج الى الانضمام الى
معاهده روما حتى حتى الان لم يتم ذلك
اتوقف مع ما تم حتى اللحظه اه ما تم حتى
اللحظه كيف يمكن استثماره قانونيا خاصه
انه اصلا اه وفقا لميثاق الامم المتحده
مد الخمسه وخمسين منه اصلا اه هنالك حق
الشعوب في تقرير مصيرهم وهذا يعني اه يعني
حصل على الفلسطينيين منذ زمن ولا يطبق كيف
يمكن تطبيق ما حصل عليه الان من جديد
يعني انه لاحظ ان فلسطين قد انضمت الى
تسعه عشر الاتفاقيه وليست وخمسطاش
الاتفاقيه فقط يعني كان هناك خمسطاشر طلب
اه منها طلب 15 اتفاقيات جنيف هنالك ايضا
اتفاقيه الاباده الجماعيه اتفاقيه مناهضه
التعذيب اتفاقيه الفصل العنصري ولكل
اتفاقيه من هذه الاتفاقيات اليات ووسائل
يمكن لنا كفلسطينيين ان نستخدمها يعني
مثلا اتفاقيه الفصل العنصري تتيح الفرصه
رفع قضايا ضد اسرائيل لما تقوم به من
اعمال العنصريه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله من خلال القوانين المحليه في مائه
وسبع الدول في العالم والتي سنه قوانين
تحارب فيها الفصل العنصري اتفاقيات
الاباده الجماعيه الان الكثير من
القانونيين الدوليين اه امثال جون دوغارد
ريتشارد فولك وغير وغيرهما يعني يقولون ان
ما تقوم به اسرائيل في قطاع غزه يشكل اه
شكل من اشكال الاباده الجماعيه فيمكن لنا
تحريك قضايا متعلقه بموضوع الاباده
الجماعيه امام المحاكم الوطنيه وايضا مثلا
في اتفاقيات جنيف يمكن تحريك بعض الامور
على المستوى السياسي والقانوني من خلال
الدول الاطراف اه في اتفاقيات جنيف
الاربعه والتي تعتبر اكثر اتفاقيات
القانون الدولي الانساني يعني اه تصديق من
قبل دول دول العالم ولكن في الحقيقه يعني
دعني اكون صريحا في هذه في هذه في هذا
المجال اه ان الفلسطينيين يحتاجون الى
الانضمام الى ميثاق روما لكي تاتي هذه
الاتفاقيات كلها بشكل اه خلي اقولك اقولك
نيتو بشكل محدد لان يعني يعني هذه
الاتفاقيات ستكون مهمه على المستوى
السياسي والمستوى المفاوضات وقد تكون
مفيده في المستوى القانوني وال مستوى ال
القضائي ولكن ال ال الفائده الحقيقيه
ستكون بعض الان دولار الاتفاقيات اه
اتفاقيه
يعني دكتور يتوقف من شيء عند الانضمام الى
هذه المعاهده لكن قبل ذلك اتفاقيه جنيف
الاربعه القانون الانساني الدولي ينظم بما
ان اه اه اتخذت صفه الدوله هنا فلسطين
ينظم علاقه اه دوله تحت الاحتلال نظم
علاقه المحتل الذي يرزح تحت الاحتلال ام
وفقا لهذه الاتفاقيات فقط بعيدا عن هل
يمكن اه ملاحقه الاحتلال لناحيه مثلا
اعطيك مثلا هدم المنازل اغلاقات حظر
التجوال هجمات على المدنيين وعلى سيارات
الاسعاف وعلى الصحفيين كل هذه الممارسات
اليوميه لاسرائيل هل يمكن وقفها من بعد
هذه الاتفاقيات
يعني وفقا لاتفاقيه جنيف الاربعه كل
الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه التي ذكرتها تشكل
جرائم خطيره او انتهاكات خطيره اه جنيف اه
بمعنى انها جرائم جرائم الحرب وان جراء
الحرب يمكن يعني ملاحقتها من خلال مجموعه
من القنوات من خلال من من هذه القنوات
المحاكم المحليه طبعا ايضا اللجان الدوليه
المعنيه بحقوق الانسان مثلا لجنه منع
التعذيب لجنه ال ال الفصل العنصري في
الامم المتحده الى عده الطفل اه كمان
غيرها من ال الجهات الدوليه ولكن كما ذكرت
الح الحقيقه ان ان التطبيق الفعلي لن يكون
الا من خلال ميثاق روما ولكن سيكون هنالك
فوائد من الناحيه الدبلوماسيه مثلا من
خلال مؤتمر الدول الاعضاء في اتفاقيات
جنيف الاربعه لان اسرائيل كانت حتى هذه
اللحظه الى حتى هذا اليوم تقول انها غير
ملتزمه باتفاقيه اتفاقيات جنيف لان لانه
لا يوجد طرف اخر مقابل
اسرائيل وعلى الضفه الغربيه هي منطقه
متنازع عليها وبالتالي لا توجد دوله يعني
يمكن لها ان تنضم الى اتفاقيه جنيف الان
الى تغير فلسطين هي دوله وهي ايضا
وبالمناسبه فلسطين اولا منذ يعني 29 11
منذ ان اثبتت الجمعيه العامه في الامم
المتحده على اعتبار فلسطين دوله صحيح دوله
مراقبه ولكنها اه دوله ولكن اه يعني اؤكد
اننا كفلسطينيين
علينا ان نستثمر هذه الخطوه من خلال يعني
هنا ادعو مثلا السيد الرئيس محمود عباس
لتشكيل لتشكيل هيئه تسمى اه يعني هيئه
القانون الدولي اولا ووزاره القانون
الدولي والتي من خلالها اه يمكن وضع
استراتيجيه لملاحقه اسرائيل عن الانتهاكات
التي تقوم بها
ال اتفاقيه جنيف وغيرها من الاتفاقيات
التي تم التوقيع عليها
شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور معك استاذ القانون
الدولي في جامعه الخليل حدثتنا من الخليل
اذن بعد ما كبرنا اغوار وتفاصيل التبعات
القانونيه لانضمام فلسطين الى هذه
الاتفاقيات والمعاهدات الدوليه سن سبر
اغوار الجزء السياسي وتبعات هذه الخطوه
بعد فاصل قصير نناقش بعده
معنا
من جديد اهلا وسهلا بكم الى ضيفي من رام
الله عبد الله عبد الله رئيس اللجنه
السياسيه في المجلس التشريعي الفلسطيني
اه سيد عبد الله البعض وصفها بانها خطوه
في الاتجاه الصحيح ولو متاخره هل ال ال
الفلسطينيين ستمضي قدما في ال اه الانضمام
الى بقيه
المعاهدات معاهده روما وبعدها ال يعني ما
ما ينتج عنها هي المحكمه الجنائيه ملاحقه
اسرائيل امنيه وسيله للضغط يد ابو مازن
للعوده الى التفاوض ونزع حقوق الفلسطينيين
عبر التفاوض
اه اولا هذه الخطوه هي حق فلسطيني منذ
تسعه وعشرين نوفمبر 2012
ولكن نتيجه لظروف ومتغيرات في المنطقه
ونتيجه التدخلات تم تاجيل هذه الخطوه
للوقت المناسب حتى نسبه كافه ال اه ال
المحاولات وكافه الخطوات اللي ممكن توصل
الى حل الصراع وفقا للمعايير والقوانين
الدوليه كونه هذا واجهت مشكله في تسعه
وعشرين نيسان هذا الشهر ينتهي الموعد
المضروب بعد ذلك اذا لم يفرج عن ال بقيه
اسرى ما قبل اوسلو وثلاثين اه في الوقت
المناسب عندها تسعه وعشرين نيسان تصبح
السلطه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه وتصبح القياده
الفلسطينيه قياده منظمه التحرير
الفلسطينيه جاهزه لاستكمال هذا الحق
وعندنا ثلاث مجموعات من المنظمات الدوليه
والمعاهدات اه سيتقدم فلسطين بطلب عضويتها
لتجسيد اعتراف الامم المتحده بفلسطين
كدوله في اه قبل سنتين او اقل
متاخره مش مشكل لكن ليست مناوره هذا حق حق
يجري وراءه وممارسه في الوقت
سؤالي السيد عبد الله الى اي حد تكون
وراءه يعني متى نرى انضمام ا الى المحكمه
الجنائيه ومحاكمه مثلا تسيبي ليفني
هذا الكلام يعطي تعرفين انه كل منظمه
دوليه او كل معاهده او كل اتفاق او كل عقد
له الياته في العضويه يعني ليست احنا كان
الاختيار الخمسطاشر اه طلب الاول لانه هذه
لا تحتاج الى اليات عندها فقط مجرد علم
وخبر
وتاخذ فتره زمنيه بعد شهر اجتماعات ثلاثه
اشهر اه بيجري مفعوله ولكن لا تحتاج الى
تصويت اي مجرد
الاعلام بالتزامن ا بمثل هذه المو في
مناسبات اخرى معاهدات اخرى منظمات اخرى في
منظمه الصحه العالميه
هذه المحكمه الجنائيه لان اه
كل هذه الاتفاقيات ان تكون في هنالك
المحكمه الجنائيه التي هي هي هي عندها
ملاحقه تلاحق مجرمي الحرب الاسرائيليين
ساعود اليك سيد عبد الله لكن اريد ان اشرك
هذه لها دورها في ترسيخ الدوله الفلسطينيه
ولكن عمليه نتحدث عن
الناحيه التنفيذيه
ماذا لو بلغ الامر بالسلطه الفلسطينيه
بالانضمام الى معاهده اه روما ايضا
وملاحقه مجرمي حرب اسرائيليين امام
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه عندها ماذا تفعل
اسرائيل
وطبعا بتتغير لكل الاحتمالات لكنها اه
تعتبر هذا الاجراء من قبل السلطه
الفلسطينيه اه انتهاكا
الذي يؤكد على اقامه الدوله الفلسطينيه من
خلال المفاوضات السياسيه اه لكي تكون دوله
قابله للحياه
الاراضي الفلسطينيه والجانب الفلسطيني
متعلق ومرتبط كل الارتباط باسرائيل انا
اعطيك مثال على ذلك العمليه اعاده البناء
والبنيه الاساسيه في قطاع غزه والتي
تمولها دوله قطر هي تمر عبر اسرائيل اه
اسرائيل اتخذت سلسله من الاجراءات للرد
على ذلك من بينها اه وقف المعاملات
الاقتصاديه التي تتعلق بالقطاع ال الضرائب
ولكن في الواقع اسرائيل لا تريد مراقبه
الشعب الفلسطيني لان الشعب الفلسطيني
ماساه هي في زعامته
التي
واصبحت
انتم تقولون تعتبرون انه اراضي المتنازع
عليها اصبحت قوميا باعتراف كل الدول على
الكره الارضيه اصبحت دوله تحت الاحتلال
وبالتالي ماساه هذا الشعب و الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي و وفقا لاتفاقيات جنيف الاربعه
عليكم كسلطه احتلال ان تعرف واجبات لكن
تجاه هذا الشعب وعلى الاقل ان توقف
المستوطنات مثلا انتم انتهكت قرارات دوليه
عده من مجلس الامن وقرار مثلا من المحكمه
الدوليه باعتبار عنصري فكيف تتحدث عن
اوسلو الان وانتم كل ما جاء بعد اوسلو
وقبله
انا اود يقول وذكر ان ماساه الشعب
الفلسطيني هي في زعامته اه منذ عام ثمانيه
واربعين بعدم قبول قرار التقسيم وبدلا من
ذلك قامت بالهجوم على اسرائيل الى خمس دول
عربيه اه وحدث ما حدث عرفات حصل على من
معاهده كامب ديفيد على خطه مين سون اه نحو
سته وتسعين
مستوطنات نحن نذهب بعيدا هذا موضوع مختلف
عليه اصلا اصلا العصابات الصهيونيه
هجرت الناس من اراضيها وذبح تعمل يعني لو
تفتح التاريخ يفتح ايضا ضدك التاريخ اه
حدثني عن
ما يمكن ما يمكن ما يمكن لاسرائيل ان
تقدمه ان تتنازل هل مثلا
من الكتل الاستيطانيه الاستيطانيه اذا
انهارت المفاوضات
ام تحت ضغط امريكي يمكن لتسويه مع ان تنتج
عن الخطوه الفلسطينيه هذه
اه لا هو طبعا فيما يتعلق
بالرغبه في مواصله محادثات السلام هذا هو
الهدف الرئيسي اه لكن اذا وصل الجانب
الفلسطيني على الخطوات ومحاربه اسرائيل
على الساحه السياسيه والدوليه اه فانها لن
يكون امام اسرائيل الا من اه يعني ان يكون
لديها بل ان بي يعني خيار ثاني اه ال
المستوطنون والمتطرفون يتحدثون على اه فرض
القانون الاسرائيلي على الضفه الغربيه
ولكن هناك اطراف في
المجتمع الاسرائيلي من بينهم وزراء سابقين
مثل الدمار يدور
والسفير الولايات المتحده اسرائيل في
الولايات المتحده الاسبق اه يقترحون
ويدعون ان نتنياهو بان يفكر بالانسحاب من
الضفه الغربيه من جانب واحد وفك الارتباط
من الضفه الغربيه على ان ينسق ذلك مع
المجتمع الدولي ومع الولايات المتحده
السيد عبد الله بكلام
التي اشار اليها بالعقوبات التي بدا بدؤوا
بفرضها وانه الاحد هنا استخدام لمفهوم
القوه و اه يعني عدم الاكتراث نهائيا
بتاتا بالقوانين الدوليه ما الخيار امام
كم اه
خيار امامنا مفتوح ولكن يبدو السيد كوهين
يعيش خارج التاريخ هو لا يعرف اين تقف
اسرائيل الان حتى في داخل امريكا امريكا
الان
شخصيات من القيادات التاريخيه في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه منها وزراء مستشارين
امن قومي منها ممثلين منها وزاره الخارجيه
ونقول السفراء في الامم المتحده يكتبوا
للرئيس اوباما انه على امريكا ان توقف
انحيازها الذي يضرب سمعه امريكا في العالم
واسرائيل اللي يمكن تستند الى اسرائيل لن
تستطيع الى
فتره طويله دعم اسرائيل
ظالمه او مظلومه ال بالنسبه لملاحقه
الاسرائيليين انا باكد لك انه اتفاقيات
جنيف الاربعه خاصه الاتفاقيه الرابعه وهذا
الاتفاق والملحق الاول التابعه لها في
العام سبعه وسبعين هذا يضع مسؤوليه على كل
دوله معترف به متعاقد اتفاقيه جنيف من ال
اكثر من مائه وستين دوله المتعاقده عليها
مسؤوليه ان تضمن تطبيق هذه الاتفاقيه
بمعنى تستطيع هي هذه الدوله المتعاقده ان
تلاحق اسرائيل على جرائمها في الداخل
الارض الفلسطينيه
عليكم قوانين
قوانين هذه قوه محتله لا يجوز ان تطبق
وانا لا يجوز ان تنقل المواطنين الى
المحتل
هي ال المجتمع الدولي اتفاقيه جنيف
الرابعه لماذا حمايه المدنيين وقت الحرب
اه اتفاقيه الثالثه الاسره لا يجوز نقل
مواطنين دوله تحت الاحتلال الى اراضي دوله
اخرى بما فيها الدوله القائمه بالاحتلال
كلها باستثناء سجن عوفر موجودين في السجون
داخل اسرائيل
يعني ليس في الارض الواقع تحت الاعداد
وهذه مخالفه هي جريمه يعاقب عليها نلاحقهم
في كل المحافل الدوليه في كل ال المحاكم
سواء يعني الان وبعد توقيع الاتفاقيه
ميثاق روما للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
من طرف واحد اي طرف واحد لا يستطيع
بها
هذه الخطوه
سيد عبد الله طيب صحيح اه هل يمكن يعني
عندما سالته هل يمكن ان تكون هذه اه اه
يعني نهايتها ان يشتري حلا
تكون تسويه حتى لا تصل اسرائيل السيناريو
الاسوء يعني من حق تعمل المحكمه الجنائيه
فيجري مثلا التخلي عن بعض المستوطنات
الحل الحل اي دوله تحت الاحتلال تحددت
حدود هذه الدوله في حدود سبعه وستين
حزيران سبعه وستين القدس الشرقيه عاصمتها
اي حل غير ذلك يكون مخالف لقرار المجتمع
الدولي بالتالي يعني لذلك الرئيس كارتر
بعث رساله الرئيس اوباما قبل ايام يقول له
على الولايات المتحده ان تحذر من تجاوز
القانون الدولي يعني اي اتفاق اطار بيحكي
فيه سيد كيري او غيره اذا كان مخالف
للقانون الدولي لا نقبله نحن والذي يقبله
العالم
ستواجه مازقا اذا استمرت في دعم اسرائيل
مواجهته بعد حرب العراق في العام الفين
يعني اذا يعني ح تغير موقفها حتى تضغط على
اسرائيل كوسيط هذا ما تقصده
حتى
ولكن احنا احنا نستند الى قوتنا الذاتيه
الى تصميمها على ملاحقه المحتل وعلى
المجتمع الدولي والقانون الدولي
مثلا خائفه من ان اه من الاصوات المتشدده
في اسرائيل التي تريد الاستمرار في التصلب
وب فرض الشروط
المستحيله يمكن ان تلقى اذانا تحذيرات
تسيبي ليفني
اه طبعا تعزيرا تسيبي ليفني هي في محلها
اسرائيل تطلع للسلام واجبات ذلك في
التوقيع على معاهده السلام ومصر وتخلت عن
ستين الف
في الاقليم
بموضوع القوى الفلسطينيه اي اين يمكن ان
تجد حلا اسرائيل في مزيد من التصلب من
ناحيتها ان في بعض التنازلات هذا ان هذا
نعم هذا بيتوقف على الجانب الفلسطيني اذا
كان الجانب الفلسطيني فعلا معنى بالوصول
الى الاتفاق عليه ان يقبل بما قدمه جون
كيري بعد تسعه اشهر من المفاوضات المكثفه
التي اجراها اربعه فلسطينيين
وتوجه الى الامم المتحده
اسرائيل
نعم ولكنه ولكن هو
لنا وافق على الدور الامريكي للوصول الى
تسويه وهو
ذلك في لقائه مع الرئيس الجميل ربما في
الشهر الماضي
انتهى الوقت
شكرا جزيلا لك من رام الله عبد الله عبد
الله رئيس اللجنه السياسيه في مجلس الشعب
الفلسطيني شكرا جزيلا لك سيد عبد الله
وشكرا